this is the story of a child found in a
tree after a storm lost until an older
couple adopts er it's not just the story
behind the hit Broadway musical once on
this island would you read it for
Michael Arden the show's director it's
the story of his life Michael Arden
director was taken in at an early age by
his grandparents listen as he reads from
his play build by oh they loved him as
their own accepted him despite not
always understanding him and allowed and
afforded him to follow his heart and
dreams Arden was raised by his loving
grandparents this production is
dedicated to their memory and to all
those who give shelter and love to those
they find in trees they found him stuck
as a toddler after family tragedy left
Arden with no one to raise him my
grandparents Jim and Pat Moore were an
incredible couple they supported me in
every endeavor I wanted or asked to be a
part of they drove me to the Community
Theatre where I did plays as a kid the
Mohr's a traditional couple from Midland
Texas did their best to understand their
grandson they sort of would come to the
plays hey oh well that's that's nice and
how do you remember all those lines I'm
also a gay man and that wasn't something
there Southern Baptist upbringing had
really prepared them for but those
differences never got in the way of
never-ending love and support he's taken
that love and support and spun it into
an acclaimed career grabbing two Tony
nominations as a director and he pays it
forward taking risks on people he finds
in trees Broadway is not ready for us
but we are ready for one of those risks
was casting a group of deaf actors in a
Broadway musical for the revival of
Spring Awakening
[Music]
able to give these young people these
deaf performers an opportunity to be
rock stars and to sign autographs at the
stage door and to be able to share their
culture with people who might never get
to see it otherwise Trishelle Edmonds
was in that cast and recently returned
to Broadway and children of a lesser God
she says Arden changed her life
particularly a black deaf actress twice
on Broadway and Michael started by
giving me that opportunity and in his
current show two major roles are
Broadway debuts Alex Newell is a male
actor ardent cast in the traditionally
female role of Asaka mother earth let's
just say this is non-traditional casting
did you say how many men in their life
get to say they get to play a strong
female and for me to get to do that
eight shows a week it's unspeakable for
me
Arden plucked Hayley Kilgore out of
college now she has a Tony nomination to
know that every day there's a little
girl that comes in and watches the show
and goes oh I could do that is I am so
lucky
Lea Salonga is the seasoned veteran what
is it in him that that makes him take
these risks
maybe it's the no one's ever done it
before hence let me be the first maybe
there's that maybe there's a pioneering
groundbreaking spirit about him
Arden recognizes that none of the
opportunities he's given others would
have been possible without the
opportunity his grandparents first gave
him what would you say if you could talk
to your grandparents if they were able
to hear you now I'd say thank you
we don't ever realize how precious life
is while we're living it and I will try
and everything I do to honor the love
that you gave